[inaudible].
Thank you very much and thanks
for coming and thanks for hosting.
Um, I'd like to tell you
about, uh, well this book,
it's a been a long journey
and it's a little unusual.
So I thought I'd tell you a bit
about, you know, how I came to, uh,
make the book and why and then
a little bit about the content.
But I'm going to save,
uh,
hopefully most of the time just to chat
with you if you would like to about, uh,
uh,
the book,
whether it be how it's
made or what's in it.
So let me tell you a festival, a
little bit about the mission. So, uh,
among the things I do besides,
uh,
research in areas of a theoretical
physicists, physics, uh,
and of course teaching the
usual Professor Gig, uh, is, uh,
I also like to be out there in the
world trying to get people excited about
science,
trying to share the excitement about
science and trying to do what I think is
very important, which is to increase
people's comfort with science.
Let it be really part of
everyday conversation.
Like any other aspect of,
of our culture. So, uh,
in that regard,
uh,
I think that we should do a better job
of embedding science in many aspects of
our lives.
And one of the things that this book
is trying to do is to encourage that in
various ways, as you'll see. So anyway,
that's meant to be sort of everyday people
out there in the world and you'll see
how it fits in later on. But let's
take a step back to the core idea.
And this goes back actually
many years, uh, to the,
uh, the sorts of questions
that people would ask me, Oh,
almost 20 years ago about,
uh,
when I'm going to write that book.
And,
and what people usually mean by that is
that an academic who's out there in the
world talking about their fields,
usually at some point writes a book and
it's a book of a certain sort. And, uh,
it's, um, it sort of,
uh,
um,
an ancient tradition and in, in,
in, in, in certain ways. And, uh,
I didn't actually feel any
urgency to write such a book.
And one of the reasons is,
is that I didn't feel we were necessarily
reaching new people with the kind of
book that we write. Um, uh,
those books are wonderful.
They do a very important service and I'll
probably end up writing some one day,
but at that time I didn't feel that the
world really needed another one from me.
And, um, I, uh,
I was also distracted by very exciting
things going on in research at the time.
Um, but the core idea that came to me was
that there was a kind of book out there
that actually I hadn't seen.
And so that got me interested
in maybe trying to do that.
And it's a sort of book
that you might, uh, um, uh,
uh,
read and feel more invited to be part
of the conversation about science.
And so the idea of
conversations about science, uh,
became sort of first and foremost in
my mind how to really celebrate those
conversations that I really know
are going on in the world out there.
And that I really think that
everyone should feel free to have.
And so a book entirely about
conversations, uh, was what came to be.
And then they realized it was
very much in the tradition of, um,
the dialogues of Plato. And also
you may know very famously of, of,
of Galileo, a lot of Galileo's
most famous ideas, uh,
that we know him for actually were first
communicated in the form of a book in
dialog form those where in some ways
the popular books of the day for those,
for those who, uh, um, who
read about such discussions.
And uh, so, so, so I have on screen, um,
a little screenshot of
a dialogues, uh, uh,
Galileo and also, uh,
the platonic dialogues,
Socratic dialogues I
should say of a Plato.
And so that was sort of the idea, but
it was still very much a prose book. Um,
but it was at least a step along the way.
The next thing I thought
it'd be interesting is to
also show what happens when
you have conversations.
You get sort of animated
into a conversation about
some aspect of science and
maybe you scribble and doodle a little
bit and those scribblings and doodles got
actually can be kind of interesting.
And I thought it'd be fun to sort of
show some of those scribbles and doodles
and a book. So it was sort of
still a prose book in my mind,
but with some illustrations showing,
showing a little bit of that
because that can be interesting.
And then as time went by, sort of
years went by, had shelved the idea,
I came back to it and then I thought,
oh,
wouldn't it be interesting to see
the people having the conversation?
That would be unusual. And
maybe that would be a way
of drawing you in some more.
You're wondering who these people are,
how did they come to meet
and so on and so forth.
So that seems like an interesting device
that could take the book further in a
direction that, uh, maybe reaches new
kinds of people. And I thought, well,
it would be nice to show where these
people are having those conversations.
And that would be great because science,
which still unfortunately has this,
this image of being,
uh,
the sort of specialized topic done
by special people in special places,
uh,
you know,
seminar rooms and labs and things where
it'd be nice to show that science is
happening. Conversations between ordinary
people out there in the, in the world.
So places these conversations in cafes
out there in the world and on trains
where people are, where people meet.
And so that was what I started,
uh, uh, imagining to do. And these
are some snapshots from what,
what eventually became the book.
Uh,
and then I got a bit carried away and,
uh,
a little bit perhaps detailed,
obsessed,
but it was very much the idea of trying
to place the conversations about science
between ordinary people out
there in ordinary places.
Some of you may or may not recognize
that's a, that's a real, uh,
location and, uh, it's, you know,
really trying to get that
idea across. So anyway, I, uh,
spent a fair amount of time
making the book and, uh,
I'll tell you a bit more
about that in a moment.
But let's first talk about
what you actually see when
you, when you, when you, uh,
when you,
when you open the book and indeed
you'll see conversations and it will be
between people,
various pairs of people and uh,
what's going on is that they're
having conversations about, uh,
ideas about our universe.
Uh, I'm writing what I know,
so I'm mostly in this, uh, incidents
are mostly talking about, um,
aspects of how our universe works. Uh,
from the point of view of physics. Uh,
in various ways. It isn't all
abstract, esoteric conversations about,
you know, black holes and the
big bang and what have you.
There's a lot of everyday science in
there as well because they think these
things are all connected.
One of the other great things about
having it in conversation form is that you
can show that connectivity conversations
aren't ever really just about one
topic,
a real conversation.
They tend to wander a little bit
and go off and sort of interesting a
serendipitous directions.
So using that and trying to represent
that and conversation allows me to show
that, uh, lots of science
topics are interconnected,
which is another nice thing
to be able to get across.
So there's conversations in cafes,
on trains between various kinds of people.
Some are scientists and we're
not scientists. And, um,
one of the fun things I also get to do is,
is,
is to break another major rule about how
the science books as supposed to work,
which is that I can show equations
and I can talk about equations.
And if you like,
you can treat the equations as part of
the art that's decorating a, the book,
um, or you can look a little
bit closer and, and, and,
and try and connect what's going on in
the equations to what's going on in the
conversation. And there are some of
the conversations that actually, uh,
don't shy away from saying, no, let's
look at these equations. It's okay.
Don't run screaming. Um, uh, you know,
you're an audience so it wouldn't run
screaming. But unfortunately, we have, uh,
this view in society that somehow
mathematics is this scary thing.
And, uh, you're advised as a, as a, as
a, as author of popular level books,
not to put equations and your
books because it'll, it'll,
it'll scare your audience
away. Every equation, uh,
supposedly half of the audience or
something like that. It has been said. Um,
I think that's ridiculous.
Uh,
mathematics is one of the
major tools of how we, uh,
arrive at ideas, uh, manipulate
ideas and, um, and uh,
have a dialogue with nature.
And why would you leave that out in any,
in any discussion, um, uh, in depth
about how science has done so.
So,
so I have that,
I have that there and actually have a
discussion between these two characters
where, where, uh, one of them
is actually saying, no, no, no.
Treat it like you treat, uh,
going into an art gallery, right?
You don't know everything
about how paintings are done,
but you can get something out of it. You
won't get everything, but that's okay.
You'll, you'll look at the painting,
maybe you'll come back another day,
you'll look again,
you'll get something else,
treat equations on the page the same way.
So that's sort of the idea is I'm
trying to change things and in terms of,
of what we do with a science books
about supposedly difficult topics.
Um,
and again,
I should emphasize there's nothing wrong
with the existing kinds of books that
are done, uh, that, uh, and that
should continue. It's, it's a,
it's just that I think we
can do so much more and, and,
and engage so many more
people. So that's, uh,
one of the core ideas of doing, uh, uh,
what I'm doing. So here's some more,
here's a more people in conversation
in various kinds of locations,
different kinds of artistic styles and
so on and so forth. Um, all in all,
what I can do is talk about
science on many different levels.
That was one of the things that I
realized, uh, when I was, uh, uh,
in the middle of doing the book after
I arrived at the idea that what I was
really doing was a graphic
novel. And to be honest, uh, it,
it hadn't occurred to me that I was doing
a graphic novel until very late in the
process until I really
had thought conversations,
um, show equations, show scribblings show
locations, and then it occurred to me,
oh my goodness, I really, really
should be doing this as narrative art.
This is a graphic novel if you
like the images had, had, had,
had eaten the pros and a and
taken over the whole book.
And then in my mind it sort of clicked.
It's a graphic novel.
As soon as I realize that, then
I realized two things. One,
no one had ever done this
before. And, uh, so I,
I really needed to do it to show
that it could be done. And second,
it allows you to do so many things in
terms of how you talk about the ideas.
Looking at the screen here, you can see
several sorts of things going on. I have,
for example, uh, showing the
scribblings as I promised,
I'm actually showing some, you know, how,
how a theorist might write some equations
about a particular issue that's being
discussed. So that's one thing I can talk
about. I can have the people talking, uh,
and you know,
speech bubbles about them talking so
you can hear what they're talking.
So that's one level I can go to a more
abstract level where I also show some of
the tools, um, in, in more
abstract sense, uh, of, of a,
of what's going on in physics,
for example. That, uh,
that diagram in the center is something a,
you may have heard of.
It's called the Feynman diagram.
It's arguably one of the most powerful
tools ever invented to compute things
that we confront with nature and test
with nature to incredible accuracy.
Um, um, and, uh, it's an amazing
tool and it's basically a cartoon.
That's what we actually use in physics.
It's a cartoon.
It belongs in a book that also
using that language. And in fact,
I build panels around it
and show, and you can, you,
if you read it in the way you're
supposed to read a comic panels,
you'll also reconstruct the physics
that's going on, which is rather nice.
So I can show that a level of abstraction,
but I can go further.
I can also talk about another level of a,
of what's going on with the
physics, uh, using this,
this mode that I really
can't do in any other medium.
And I'll say a little bit about that
shortly. And then I can also, uh,
have the,
uh,
the conversation lists either
with real or imagined objects,
engage with the physics as well.
So that's another sort of visual level
that I can play with all on the same page.
So there's really no other medium
that can do this. And I, I feel this,
there's a lot of potential here for,
for doing so much more, uh, in this, uh,
in this space, uh, with this
mode of, uh, of communication.
And then I can also do
some, some, uh, some playful
things. For example, here's a,
a couple talking in a, in a, in
a, in a, in a square at a table,
and they're actually talking about the
physics of multiverses and black holes
and so on and so forth. And
there's an idea of how, um, uh,
you have a branching structure
where, where, um, uh, universities,
uh, uh, in, in some theory separating from
each other and branching out and, and, uh,
I'm actually without banging
it too much on the head,
you're viewing that you're viewing them
through the branches of an overhead tree.
And so there's again, a
resonance with the, with the, uh,
with the conversation in the, uh,
in the decoration if you like.
And then I can go really a sort
of off the reservation and,
and also have sort of big metaphorical
discussions. They actually start,
this couple starts, um, having
a fanciful discussion, uh,
about some physics analogies
with, uh, with ideas and, um,
in, in, in paradise lost.
And I can actually go crazy and actually
sort of draw bets and things like that
as well. So, so you, you can really
play on many levels in the service of,
of, of having fun, uh, with the
idea and really, um, still, uh,
have a serious discussion about
some important ideas in science.
So let me say a little bit about methods
because people are very curious about
how you make these things and
how I went about making it. Um,
well, it all goes down to, uh,
figuring out whether I could draw a,
at the level needed to, uh, to
carry it, to carry this off. And,
and the answer is that I, that I couldn't
at the beginning, I had to teach myself.
And, uh, you know,
this as a side remark is a very
important thing to emphasize,
which is that drawing, uh, like
many other things, uh, is, is,
is mostly a learned skill that you can
actually set out to learn and, and, uh,
and practice and do it.
It's,
it's very little to do with the mythology
of natural talent and so on and so
forth. So, um, I could, you know,
do a bit of drawing and
sketching like anyone else,
but I really had to put in the time to
just practice and learn the skill set
needed and then study the actual,
a whole industry of how you make
graphic novels and um, and uh,
and try and learn those techniques.
But mostly there's just putting
in the time to draw. So, uh,
the caring sketch books
around with me and, uh, um,
just a drawing every time
I got the opportunity.
Mostly trying to understand
the human body, the human face.
So trying to,
uh,
get as many opportunities as possible
and public transport is just great for
that.
Um,
although it's getting a bit annoying now
because most people that are like this
because you know, phones, but, um,
maybe I'll do an entire book of the
tops of People's heads some point.
Um, but anyway, uh, so, so,
uh, you know, a lot of, uh,
a lot of practicing, uh,
various kinds of, uh, uh,
techniques, um, uh, uh, going into, uh,
life drawing studios and just,
uh, um, uh, practicing on,
on the,
on,
on the human body to learn
anatomy and practicing faces,
practicing digital techniques and,
uh, also traditional techniques,
drawing buildings,
drawing buildings out there in the world,
as that's a lot of fun. I stumbled upon
the whole urban sketchers movement,
which is wonderful, by the way,
if you don't know about it,
just Google urban sketchers and you'll
find there's a whole movement of people
who just go out, that you actually,
sometimes around London for example,
or any big city, you'll, you'll, you'll
see groups of people just sketching,
just sort of, they've just descended and
they're sketching and it's actually a,
it could well be one of the urban
sketchers meetups. And, uh, that's,
that's actually a fun thing
to do. I never had the, uh,
never had the time or, or courage
to, uh, to, to join such a group.
I'm a bit more of a solitary
sketcher myself, but, um,
maybe I will one day cause it's a, it's
a great way of encouraging each other.
I understand.
So anyway,
a lot of techniques
then, uh, I learned, uh,
particularly to do with make it going
from just doing sketches to, to,
to learning more graphic styles
that are appropriate for, for,
for graphic novels and learning how to
deal with light and shade and things like
that. And then, yes, a old
fashion techniques, which I love,
like doing a lot of perspective
construction by hand,
but then also learning how to
do perspective construction
on computer to speed
things up and things
like that. Um, and uh,
and then traditional banking and digital
banking and so on and so forth. Uh,
moving forward, uh, here are
some examples of sort of,
uh,
before and after sketching out ideas
which eventually turned into final pages.
Um,
the part of the process which people
sometimes find interesting in some cases I
wrote conversations and then designed
images to go with them and other cases I
did, I designed images. Uh,
at the same time as I was thinking about
what the conversation around them would
be a dependent upon the nature of the
topic. And also where I was in the,
in the process I started
in around 2010, um, having,
having realized it should be
a graphic book pack in 2006,
it took me a while to find the time.
And then I had a sabbatical in 2010.
And so I started trying to see if I
could teach myself to draw at that higher
level. Um, and then I was
drawing from 2010 until 2016.
I'm actually 2017. And,
uh, so, uh, styles change,
techniques change, workflow, uh, methods
changed and so on and so forth. Um,
and uh,
so these are just some examples of
a sketching turning into the final,
uh,
product.
Okay.
And, uh, this is,
this is a good example of a sketch that
was done at the same time as the ideas
and then turns into the
final, uh, discussion, uh,
that you see on whatever
page it is in the book. Okay.
Um, let me move on.
There was a, uh, another,
um, interesting, uh,
level one can get too,
which I think is worth talking
about a little bit. And, and uh,
I sort of think of it, this is the,
the discovery that people tend to ask,
you know, they go, well, you're
a scientist doing research.
He was taking time out to this other
thing. And then the question always is,
has that other thing informed,
uh, informed your, your,
uh, your physics? Have you,
have you discovered anything because
you've been doing art? And, um,
so the honest answer
is, um, not really. Um,
I wish, I wish there was a, a
fantastic story. I could tell you. Um,
uh, you know, there's, there's,
there's nothing I'm going to be writing
up in the journal anytime soon. Um,
that that came from, from, uh,
from, from this enterprise.
And I don't think that is a necessary
thing to legitimize, uh, doing this.
I think, uh, the, the mission we were
talking about at the beginning is, is, is,
is more than enough. Um,
but I should say, uh,
generally speaking,
the process by which you think clearly
or try to think clearly about how to
explain ideas to people always
reflects, uh, um, always, uh,
uh, back, reacts positively on how
you think about your actual research.
And I'm sure many of you know that.
So,
so there probably are things as I think
about more clearly as a result of having,
um, put the time into figuring
out how to say it in a,
in the book. Um, but I do, I
do have a little bit of a joke,
but there's a very serious point,
uh, that, that, uh, that I,
I did discover a new equation and that's
the equation. Comics equals physics.
And there's actually a serious point,
uh, those of you who are maybe a,
I have more than a passing
interest in comics know that, uh,
there's a well established, um, thing
that said, uh, it said very well.
And for example, Scott McCloud's
books or um, or, um, uh,
will Eisner's books about how sequential
artworks that comics are not a passive
medium. Um, uh, you actually as a reader,
you're doing something very active
and what you're doing is your, your,
your taking a sequence of images
that are laid out in a certain order.
Um, uh, and with a certain
convention about the audio,
read them in a and w w once you,
once you do that,
what you're doing is
you're creating space.
You're creating an active sense
of space and also have time.
There's a sense of passing of time.
And it's very important when
you're designing comics to
actually understand that,
um,
because it allows you to play with.
It allows you to manipulate how the
reader gets what you're trying to get them
to get a off the page. Um, and, uh,
so that's sort of a well known thing,
but I,
I think one can go actually much further
than that because in much of the book
I'm talking about ideas about
space and time in physics.
And so what better medium,
uh,
to have that kind of
discussion in, uh, then,
uh, then, uh, a book that's, you know,
depends so much on the reader
to construct space and time. So,
uh,
with that in mind,
I can actually start playing with
the physics ideas by playing with the
structure of the page in terms of how
the panels are laid out and things like
that. Um, so comics equal physics
is sort of a serious thing.
I think physics is extremely
well adapted to comics. Uh,
the construction of space and
time that happens in comics. Um,
allows you then to do things like
this. A, there's a conversation where,
uh, the, the,
the discussion that's taking place in
the field right now about what may happen
in the early universe,
for example,
around the time of the big
bang or slightly before,
depending upon how you define the big
bang space and time itself may not be very
much if at all.
Um,
even close to the way we think of space
and time right now. It may break down in,
in,
in certain interesting ways.
So I can actually have that
conversation taking place.
And while it's taking place in words,
it's also happening in the
panel structures where the
panel itself is dissolving
in a way analogous to what's supposed
to be happening to space and time,
the space and time of our universe
that's being this, uh, this,
this solution that's happening
here actually spreads out onto, um,
onto, uh, another, um,
another page. And, uh, and,
and it continues there in an interesting
way. So it's a little bit playful here.
It's not essential to discussion,
but it certainly, uh, having the,
the page itself resonate with the idea.
I think is another way of getting, uh,
getting it to sort of sink in what's
going on. And, uh, so that sort of Nice.
Um, and, uh, it was a fun
thing to do once I realized,
I realized very late in the process,
um, that this was a possibility.
So I probably would've done a lot more
headache, realized that earlier and I, I,
it would be fun to revisit
some of that, um, in, in, uh,
in perhaps in a, in a sequel.
Here's another, um, uh, perhaps
a more subtle example, uh,
two people that are discussing what,
uh, what's, uh, thought to happen,
uh,
following Einstein's equations.
Um, uh, yeah,
uh,
in the interior of a black hole.
Okay.
And,
uh,
so they're discussing the whole idea
of as you go deeper and deeper into the
black hole of various kinds
of things happen. Um, but, uh,
one of the things that Einstein's
equations, uh, tells you happens,
which we actually think probably gets
strongly modified by quantum effects,
that we're still trying to figure out,
um,
is that a space and time
begin to, uh, get, uh,
confused what you thought
of a space is now time,
what you thought of his time is now space.
It's all getting very confused.
So again,
I had that in words,
but then the other thing I do
on this page is I have, um,
a resonance a with that idea by having
the order in which you read the panels be
the wrong order. So I'm sort of
breaking down space and time, uh,
that you construct as the reader and
breaking that down. You're reading in a,
in a, in a cyclic order as
opposed to the one, two, three,
four you would normally do in
order to make sense of those words.
And so I'm sort of playing with your
head a little bit as you're reading about
the breakdown of space and time. Uh,
you're getting some, some dissonance,
some confusion on the page as well,
which is, uh, which is deliberate, again,
trying to show,
uh,
through the panel structure
that something's funny is
happening inside the black
hole. So, um, uh, I'll,
I think I'll end there, but just, just
end with a few hopes and the hope is, um,
that, uh, people find this
interesting. People engage with it.
But also I hope that this
isn't just a, uh, uh,
a random weird quirk.
And then we just go back
to the usual way of,
of discussing science in the
public sphere. I, you know,
I hope that maybe a other,
uh,
writers,
scientists,
artists might engage more
with using science. I'm sorry,
using comics and graphic novels for
serious discussion of science. You,
there are lots of, uh, graphic
treatments or science out there,
but they're either, um, uh,
done with maybe more of a
comedic bent or more, you know,
more like the sort of Sunday funnies or,
you know, sort of Gee Whiz, kind of, uh,
science stuff or stuff, uh,
for, for children, all of
which are wonderful things.
This is not any of those things.
I think a, a serious discussion,
um,
uh,
where science has the star in character
as opposed to it being a biography or
something. It's something that you don't
really see much, certainly in physics, um,
in graphic novel form.
And so I, I hope to,
I hope that can change and this is an
attempt to show that this is something
that can be done, uh, can be, uh,
successful in terms of
communicating the ideas and, um,
and get people excited.
So a,
I'm going to stop babbling
now and maybe hear from you
mmm.
As a professor in the university to do,
do teaching students stations,
do you use some of your skills and
all those ideas during the rotation?
Like just usual lectures and all that?
Um, that's an interesting question.
I certainly don't have, um,
know full on graphic narratives,
uh, in, in my teaching.
Um, uh, you know, I might, uh, it's
been a while since I, uh, for example,
total freshmen class and maybe
I might do it there. Um, uh,
it's um,
right,
here's his assault something
I'll say. Yeah, something else.
I think this book is, um, uh,
trying to do is to show just how visual,
um,
the field actually is.
And it is already the case that in
the classroom or in the seminar room,
uh,
where one's talking about physics,
but one's actually doing physics
research as well. It's very, very visual.
And I don't think that's appreciated
because ironically we have our ideas.
Um,
you know,
we may be billed multibillion dollar
machines to discover the particles that
came about as a result of those ideas,
what have you.
And then we go out and we write
books about it. And, and, and we're,
and we're encouraged to and in fact,
take pride in and communicating it
all in words and pretending that we'd
actually didn't have this
huge visual component. So,
so actually one of the things
I'm trying to do is, is, um, is,
is talk more about that visual component,
have that visual component
much more upfront. So in my,
so my classroom is already very visual,
um,
in the sense that if you walk into
my class and look on the board,
you will see drawings because
that's what we use. Uh, uh,
whether it be the equations or diagrams
is associated with the equations or even
sort of metaphorical sketches about
what the interior of the black hole is.
We do that all the time already.
So,
so in some ways I'm just bringing
more of that to the page than normally
happens.
That is significant efforts to,
uh,
earlier ice public with the
physics, the physics, for example,
the space time or the
third fermilabs programs.
So how do you come where the video way
of presenting things with the comic way
of a comic book way of presenting things?
I mean,
this is a great question. Um,
those are wonderful things. Um,
and I apologize, you will see
my face on a number of them too.
Um, and, and uh, and uh,
those again, things should be,
it should continue. Uh, but, but three
different, I think, I think video, um,
uneven animation in video form
of ideas is a wonderful thing,
but it's still quite different.
Um,
in some ways it's still much more passive.
I think reading of any form it engages,
engages the reader,
uh,
in exploring the ideas and fitting it
into their head much more than sitting and
watching, uh, a thing. Um, so, uh,
so in some ways, um, the
comic form, uh, the graphic,
the graphic novel form is, is, uh, is,
is in a very interesting space that's
along a sort of different access,
but it has commonality
with the other forms,
but then it has this whole
thing unto itself. Uh,
in terms of some of the things I
mentioned before, that active engagement,
you're creating some of the,
the space that's being a,
that's being imagined are on many
different levels. All those things.
I can't think of another
medium that does that.
People often think of comics as
basically stills of a movie. And that,
that's such a, such an
unfortunate perception. It's
so much more than that. And,
and, and so that's why it's incredibly
frustrating to me that comics are still
thought of as either,
you know,
things for kids or things to talk
about superheroes, um, or, or,
you know,
something that is so much less than
what they can be. And, and, and,
and so,
so,
so what I'm trying to do here is show
just how much this form can contain if we
take it seriously and bring serious
topics to it. So I hope that,
yeah,
and I'm guessing it's much harder to
revise and this kind of presentation.
So if you,
if you get struck as you say with an
interesting idea of how you could do
something,
it will be a lot of effort to go back
and change what you've already done.
Is that going to be a
barrier to more of this kind
of book?
Um,
uh, I'm not sure. It depends. It
depends upon the kind of change.
Um,
it possibly also depends upon,
uh,
I'm not sure it's any harder,
a harder than re-editing a movie perhaps.
Um, yeah, I'm not sure how
to answer that. Yes, it can.
It can be, uh, difficult
to, uh, make changes,
particularly if you've designed,
if you're really using the medium,
well then the page layout is crucial.
Making a change here could have a knock
on effect on other parts and so on and
so forth. And I think of
that as a positive thing
because it shows that it's a,
it's something very complex going on
and so difficult in making changes,
you know, that's a thing. But I think
if it's worth doing, it's worth doing.
I'm not sure how it, how else
to answer that, but it's a,
it's a good observation though. Um,
I, I think, um, there are, you know,
I've learned a lot about how
to do things quickly, uh,
as compared to when I first started
out. You know, I, I think, um,
I think when I was first doing this or
of course even taking into account that I
was
doing it in my spare time and
not full time, uh, it w it would take
a very long time just to do one page.
By time I got to, uh, the final
sprint to hand it in on, on,
you know, on deadline to the
publisher. Uh, I was doing, um, uh,
uh, more than one page per day.
Sometimes depending upon the style, uh,
you know, a couple of pages a day
of, of, of, of final art. Um, so,
so there, there are many different sort
of types of technique and workflow,
some of which are easier to
make adjustments to than others.
It really depends upon one's
one's own chosen style.
Okay.
Back to,
well other media.
I was just wondering about what a
woman could do something similar with
interactive web based
type presentation,
possibly comic based as well,
but with the directive.
Yeah, there's, there's,
there's interactive, um,
there's interactive things that can be
done on, on, on the web, on devices.
Um, uh, there's also, uh,
the growing perhaps medium of
motion comics and things like that.
I think the many things that can be done,
um, with, uh, with digital techniques, um,
that could be in the spirit of this or,
or,
or go off in another direction
or a law again on a, on a, on a,
on a somewhat different access, uh, to
explore different aspects. Um, so yes,
uh, let's, let's do them all.
You talked about being inspired by
a lot of the classic dialogues and
all the ones I'm familiar with are between
a teacher and a student to our master
and a scholar where it seems like one
of the Pr people is just there to ask
leading questions.
Um,
did you find yourself using that same
frame since I've only spent 10 seconds
with the book or did you find
another way to modernize it or do,
um, you'll find mixtures of that. I
mean, it's certainly the case that, um,
that there are some pairings that one
person has more expertise in the other.
Um, but I still didn't want it
to be even in that case. Well,
in all of those cases where that happens,
I still don't want it to
be master and student. Um,
because I think that almost defeats
the purpose of what I was trying to do.
Going back to my,
uh,
my non critique of the sort of
standard books that we write.
Um, uh, one of the other things that can
turn people off is that that tone of,
here I am stepping out of the ivory
tower to tell you how you're supposed to
think about things. And they really
wanted to avoid that tone. Um, and,
uh, so even when it is an
expert in the non-expert,
they really equals out there in the
world. And, and people often go, oh,
but it's just another lecture
cause that presence an expert.
And so they're not ordinary people out
there in the world. And I want to go,
actually,
scientists are ordinary people and we
can be out there in the world and we do
drink coffee and take the
train and so on and so forth.
And we meet ordinary people in the world
just like we, we're ordinary people.
And so you,
you'll see,
you will see pairings where that's
helpful in order to get somewhere with the
material. Um, in a longer version
of this book, um, uh, you know,
before I had to make decisions
about the final content,
there actually are more conversations
between non-experts and, and,
and I wanted the freedom to,
uh,
allow people to say things that
actually aren't right as well,
to make guesses about things or to
extrapolate and wrong directions.
But then what has to be much more careful
about finding ways than of undoing
that so that you're not
getting people walking away
from that story, uh, with, um,
with, uh, with, with the wrong
impressions. And, and there are some,
there are some example
as examples of that,
but fewer of them made it to this book.
But I will be revisiting that.
And I'm curious about your decision
early on to decide to go straight to
yourself and I'm wondering whether you
could share some thoughts about the pros
and cons of either doing the visual side
yourself or partnering with someone,
you know,
have you thought about the disadvantages
and what advice would you have to other
academics and researchers
who are interested in doing
that? That's, that's a
great question. Um, uh,
great.
The decision Wa well,
okay.
Some of you may have a theoretical physics
background. I have a, I don't know,
but certainly in our field and maybe
another in other sort of research areas
like that where we're constantly,
that process by which we go,
my research is taking me into that
direction and there's a whole bunch of
techniques, um, uh, you know, new kinds
of code or new kinds of mathematics or,
or new kinds of physical ideas that I
either need to teach myself or just invent
in order to go off in that direction.
So it's just sort of common to do that.
So my first instinct always is,
and it's the way I've always
been since I was a kid, is just,
just figure out what I need
to go in that direction.
So that was my first instinct. Um, and uh,
uh,
collaborating though is a wonderful thing.
And, uh, one of the things I was
concerned about, however, is that a, well,
the two fold one is that there really
wasn't anything else like this out there.
So trying to work with some,
I, you know, I already,
when I first tried to explain to people
what it was I was trying to do, um,
uh, I kept getting people, uh, you know,
trying to make guesses what
they thought were helpful,
suggestions about what the book should
be based on what people do. You know,
what they already know. And,
and I kept going, no, no,
no, I don't want to do that.
I don't want to do,
I didn't want to do an adventure story.
I don't want to do a biography.
I don't want to do it. Blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah,
blah.
And so at some point I just stopped
telling people about it because they were
trying to essentially infiltrate my
idea with just making me do more of the
same.
Um,
my worry then also is trying to
get a professional artist, uh,
on board is that I would also have that
process whereby I'd be trying to explain
to them that I wasn't trying to do this.
I wasn't trying to do that other thing.
This is what I'm trying to do. And I
just, I, and, and so there was this,
this anticipation of the frustration
of that process. I just thought,
let me get least first,
see whether I can just do it myself.
Then there's also the issue of if I'm
getting an artist that doesn't necessarily
know any science, um, uh,
I would then be spending a fair
amount of time translating and,
and some things may be lost
in translation. They may
do this beautiful page,
but you know, the actual idea I
was trying to, yeah. And then,
and then also, I think you missed you. I
would've had, I had I gone with an artist.
I think I probably wouldn't have delved
into researching how graphic novels work
as much as I did and I wouldn't have
discovered, you know, my equation,
quote unquote,
uh,
the idea that there are opportunities
in the structure of the medium itself to
resonate with the physics
ideas. And, uh, I, I,
I simply would not have come upon
that and I think that was a value.
So, um, so, uh,
it certainly is not the only way of
doing this. However, um, and I think,
um, people are very welcome to, to, to,
to try it in different ways,
either doing the,
doing the art themselves or,
um,
or working with a collaborator.
There also are very good artists out
there who also appreciate and love science
and, and, uh, you know, really champing
at the bit to do this kind of project, uh,
with, with a physics collaborator. There's
a actually a really good example. Um,
um, the Phd Comics Guy Jorge Charm, uh,
collaborated with Daniel Watson to do,
it's not quite a graphic novel,
but it's a,
it's a prose book with lots of Fun
Phd comic style illustrations and,
and, and, and they're, you know, they
both engage with the science in, in, in,
in that project. And so the
collaborations like that, but there,
there could also be very sort
of, uh, um, writerly, sorry,
a scientist is writer, artist
type, uh, collaborations,
um, uh, where, you know, you just,
you just collaborate on trying to tell
the story as best you can. So, um,
I,
I think all those,
all those methods will produce
interesting books and I think, um,
we should try all of those things.
I just think we've been,
we've just for a field that's normally
very, very innovative, which is physics,
I think we've been really behind
the curve on innovations in books,
uh, for, for how we get people excited.
So it's time to start trying
all sorts of things. Um,
some, uh, lots of concepts in equations
and physics seem to lend themselves quite
naturally to visual
ways of explaining that.
I think some are a
really abstract and with,
were there any that you kind of
wanted to include in the book,
but you're actually
stumped and you thought,
actually I just can't explain
this in a simple way. Um, hmm.
Yeah, I haven't, uh, I that certainly
didn't happen in the process of, of,
of doing the book I had.
Okay.
Maybe I, maybe I had already, uh, uh,
preselected ideas that lend themselves
well to being expressed visually when it,
when I was sort of
carving, um, uh, you know,
carving out a chunk to put into the book.
Um,
since then I have been
thinking about it. Um, I,
I would like the opportunity
perhaps to visit, um,
uh,
more deeply some ideas from
quantum physics in this form. Um,
usually what happens is you end up
just drawing lots of fuzzy blobs and,
you know, there's a, there's a,
there's a point and then there's
a fuzzy blob and what have you.
And Quantum fuzziness,
uh, gets used a lot,
but not really exploiting
that form very much.
And I do wonder whether there are
ways of doing it. So I, you know,
let's see,
maybe there'll be a volume to where I
actually try and use the comic form full
on two to address concepts
in quantum physics. Um,
we'll see. I actually to, uh,
wanted
to come back a little bit more to
your question with regard to the, the,
the sort of status of the, of the,
uh, interlocutors, uh, because, uh,
not, not only I do, I think of them
and hopefully present them as equals.
Um, but I also show in many cases
where the, the, the perhaps,
uh, confident expert is, is, is, is,
is tripped up by some of the
questions. Uh, and, and, and,
or maybe they push back on each other
in ways so that there's a, for example,
a conversation on the train
where, um, where, uh, um, to,
to, to people one, an expert at one,
an astrophysicist and one
whatever it is, they do, um, uh,
start discussing the nature of time and
it goes off an interesting philosophical
directions and also,
uh, directions do with,
with a black hole physics and also
directions to do with religion.
And they really push against each other
in interesting ways as, as equals, uh,
coming from their own perspectives, uh,
to that conversation. So, so, you know,
I hope that's another example of it
not being sort of master student. Yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
What do you want it to say?
Whether you had
made a decision to want fans of science,
the expert?
Well for someone who enjoys reading about
the theories of silence or trained as
working in the this area.
Um, uh, definitely, uh,
it's meant to be a book that I
hope one day to be, you know,
on the pick of the design and just see
a random person from a random field
of a random age of a random
background reading. I really,
I really want to make it sort of for
everybody. In fact, I had this battle,
uh,
you know,
I could give you an entire talk about
trying to get a book that's this unusual
published,
uh,
because people want you to say
very narrowly what group of,
what demographic is this for.
Uh, and, and, and I really
pushed back against that.
I think it should be possible to
create books that offer everybody,
not in some sort of vague sense, but
in the very specific sense of, uh,
we need to let go of the idea that
you can open a book and necessarily,
uh, uh, read it from cover to cover
and get everything that first time.
Um,
in fact,
if you're writing a book about complex
ideas that people have been researching
on for hundreds of years, if, if,
if someone can pick it up and,
and read it just all in one,
go and get everything,
uh,
maybe you're not trying
hard enough because I think,
I think difficult ideas should,
uh,
I mean difficult quote unquote cause
difficult as a matter of perspective. Um,
uh, should, uh,
should lead you should
leave you wanting more.
You should be able to engage with it to
some level and maybe not get everything
and have the joy of coming back later
and finding that you understand more or
going, okay, that gave me a taste
of, uh, what this idea is like.
Um, and now I'll, uh,
I'll, uh, I'll, I'll,
I'll go do something else for a while,
um,
or have a sense of why it's important
if I didn't get all the ideas.
So what I'm trying to say is
that, um, uh, I hope the book is,
is an invitation to
engage with these ideas.
Um, not necessarily, um,
all chapters will be for everybody.
Um,
there are some chapters that perhaps go
into a little bit more technical detail
then some other chapters.
Um,
but still none of those chapters
are meant for experts. Um, uh, they,
they really,
they really are not.
Um, uh, yeah, uh, yeah,
uh, they really offer, you
know, the lay person, um, uh,
interested in science and
there's a huge, um, uh,
number of people out there who
have a thirst for science ideas.
Um, some of them will go to the section
of the bookstore that says science and
they'll go and pick up a book.
And many of them, actually,
most of them don't go to that section.
They prefer to think of themselves
maybe as visual people or however they,
you know, whatever box they
want to put themselves in.
And they'll watch a documentary
on TV or something like that,
but they won't pick up
no
Roger Penrose or, uh, you know, um,
frank wheelchair or any of these really
interesting writers engaging with
science, uh, through through
book form. Um, hopefully, uh,
this book is, is, is a way that
might get them to get excited.
They're also people who might pick it up
thinking it's a graphic novel and it is
a graphic novel and find, Oh, science
is actually kind of interesting. Um,
what I did is at the end of every chapter,
I have lots of suggestions
for further reading,
so I will send them to find out more in
Roger Penrose or frank wheelchair or you
know,
any of the other really great writers
out there who are thinking about things,
uh, in prose form that presenting
things in prose form and um,
but they might get a taste of the
beginning of the ideas first, um,
uh, in, um, in, in the book.
So I don't know if that
answers the question is sort
of a long rambling answer,
but I think it's a,
it's a complex issue.
Yes.
I think, I think you might've claim, yeah.
Where did you kind of see the book sitting
in, in the big stuff, even that it's
fictional content within
a fictional setting. Yeah.
And how you would avoid kind of
confusion with that. This, um,
this has caused me a set many
and continues to cause me many.
Uh,
I was nights I've lost sleep because I,
that I,
that point I lose control because now
it's all about the publisher and the
bookstores, but actually more the
bookstores than anything else.
And the problem is that,
um,
people will pick up the book and they're
trying to decide what shelf to put it
on. And despite the fact
that I keep screaming,
it's a nonfiction book about science.
And first and foremost,
that's the section it belongs in.
But it's very hard to go into one of
these bookstores and find it there.
Um, uh, because I think people will
just go, oh, it's got pictures.
It's the children's book.
So I actually just the other day had to
politely ask for someone to move it from
the children's book section to the science
book sections. Right. Right. Over there.
And, uh, and then, and then,
or it might be in the graphic book section
and the graphic novel section, which,
which I'm happy with too. Um, uh,
I would like it ideally to be in all
of those sections. Now, of course,
bookstores only have limited shelf
space, so that's a hard sell. Um,
uh, so, um, I, I would
really love to see it,
to answer your question directly,
my fantasy about where it should be
is on those tables in the middle,
um, where people can stumble on
it and, and, and see that it,
it, it, it, it both doesn't, doesn't
fit in any of those sections. And I,
I really think they should be more room
for books that are hard to classify.
Unfortunately.
And this,
the way things are set up now is
something is hard to classify.
It disappears because people get confused
and there's just too much effort.
So let's not even worry. So, so that's
the thing. I'm, I'm, I'm fighting most,
uh, um, uh, uh,
right now I'm at the stage of the book's
out. It's also difficult to get it,
uh, um, sort of talked about
by the usual outlets because,
you know, a publication
for example, goes, well,
this our graphic novel people
should talk about that.
It's the comic book and
the Comic Book People Go,
but there was no superheroes or it's,
you know, not a tortured memoir. So,
or it's got too much science in it. And so
it ends up, again, getting, getting lost.
So it, it's, it's, it's
one of the frustrations.
So I'm hoping that in this world where
a word of mouth has a lot more power
through social media and things like that,
that I can combat some of
that classification problem
by just having people talk
about it and go, hey, I really enjoy this.
I don't care what section it goes in. Uh,
I enjoyed reading it, so that's, that's
the hope. So please talk about it.
Uh,
yeah.
So you both mentioned in the introduction
that you consulted on superhero movies
and I was wondering about that
just a fun thing for you should do,
or was it another way to try engage people
with science and how do you reconcile
like,
having real science and also
in the context of those movies?
I mean, like fantasy, divine
magic sign habits. So both,
right. Yeah. Um, so to the first
part of your question, um, um,
I think of it as real work. Uh,
it's one of the problems I have, uh,
doing this kind of work,
putting serious hours into science
advising for the entertainment industry.
Um, people assume I'm just sort of
goofing off with my Hollywood buddies. Um,
and, and don't realize that it
takes a huge amount of work, uh, to,
to, you know, to do it in a, in
a useful, um, uh, impactful way.
Um, uh, and it varies
from project to project.
Sometimes it's a conversation. Other
Times I'm reading, uh, you know,
uh, for example, for the, I know
if you saw that show, um, uh,
about Einstein's life and work
last year called genius, um,
you know, with that I was teaching
them a lot of the science.
I was helping them select aspects
of the science that could be used to
illustrate Einstein's life.
And I was,
I was giving a detailed notes
on every hour long script, uh,
and, uh, you know, doing a lot of back
and forth. That's a lot of time. Um,
why do I do it? Because I think it's
incredibly an incredibly powerful medium.
It's where, uh, you know, whatever
age group you're talking about,
whether it be adults or children or what
have you, that's where the eyeballs are.
Um, uh, as, as soon as they leave the
classroom or as soon as people leave work,
they're going to entertainment.
So why wouldn't we be there if we,
if we really care about science
being part of our every day, uh,
engagement. So for me, I think, um, uh,
that's a marvelous space to be involved
in when I get the opportunity, uh,
to get people excited
about science. Now. Uh,
so I do both fiction and nonfiction,
uh, projects when I can. And I,
I think they're equally important. Again,
there's a whole bunch of people will,
who will go and watch a thing about
Einstein or who will watch a documentary
about, you know, the nature of time
and what have you. And so sure,
I put a lot of effort into,
into, into those as well.
But there's a whole bunch of people who
potentially can be engaged by science
who will never go and see
those things on those channels.
But they'll go and see the latest movie
about Thor or the Avengers or what have
you.
And if I can sneak some ideas in there,
uh, that can have benefit to it
might be a lot fewer science ideas,
but it's millions more people.
So you never know where it might,
where it might have some value.
Now I should take a step and ask about
this whole business is sneaking some
science in because it isn't that I'm sort
of putting spinach into your milkshake.
As I, as I, as I, uh, as I like
to say, I'm sure of showing,
hoping to show that,
um,
there's all kinds of flavors of
milkshake that people haven't,
uh, um, uh, engaged with, uh, that,
that could be really awesome. And, um,
the,
the core point there are,
when I talk with filmmakers who
don't care about the mission,
perhaps some do,
but really it isn't their main motivation
to care about the mission of science
education.
But I can help them tell more interesting
stories and that gets people buying
more tickets. So if, if
you, uh, reasonably, uh,
uh, uh, uh, well,
sort of cognizant people about how,
how the universe works,
go into a movie and you can see they've
done a sloppy job of making the whole
story believable because the
world building is problematic, um,
it pops you out of the movie.
You,
you're probably not going to
go see it three times. Like,
you know, like, like you,
you, you, you may, uh, if, if, if
you really sort of engaged with it.
So even though they might be people
with magic flying hammers and you know,
doing all sorts of crazy things,
if it has the feeling of, of,
of a, of at least for the two
hours that you're in the movie of,
of feeling like it's a
scientifically coherent world,
even though it's not
our world, um, then, uh,
you're telling a better story and,
and uh,
and who better to ask about how to build
universes and rules for universes than
people who study this universe and study
its rules. So, so, so that, that's,
that's sort of the, the job I think I can,
I can do if they let me, unfortunately,
most of Hollywood still hasn't
realized that last part. Um,
so it's still fairly random as
to how much they let me, uh,
get involved in those projects.
But when they do,
I can usually give them some fun stuff.
We are running out of time.